Hello. Welcome to today's episode of Rawkode live.
This is the clustered series. A show in
which
me and a friend and guests will do
our best to fix broken Kubernetes clusters. The
catch is they are broken by members of
the Kubernetes community
and weird, wild, wonderful, and scary ways.
Now, before we can begin
today,
I've got a little bit of housekeeping. First,
please subscribe and click the bell on YouTube
so you get alerts and notifications for more
episodes of Clustered and the other cloud native
content that I am producing.
Also, if you are Discordian
inclined and like to chat, we always have
an active community of people chatting about cloud
native Kubernetes and a whole bunch of other
stuff. Come and join us. And finally,
I need to thank and want to thank
my employer Equinix Medal.
They provide the time and resources for me
to invest in this show
and hopefully produce learning materials so that we
can all learn together. If you wanna check
out Equinix Medal, you can use the code
to Rawkode live. It will get you $50
in credit, which is around one hundred hours
of compute. So enjoy.
Let's see if I remember how to make
that disappear. Hey. There we go. Alright. Now
today, I am joined by.
Hey, Duffy. How's it going?
Quite well. Quite well. It's going great. I'm
looking forward to this one. This will be
super fun. Great to see such an awesome
audience. Good to see you, Sam and Rich.
I think Sam might be giggling glee in
the background, but I'm not sure.
Yes. Definitely. We've got loads of comments coming
in. I'll get a few more of those
on while we chat. Do you wanna just
give us the quick TLDR on Duffy, who
you are, what you're up to, and then
we'll get started.
Sure. I'm a I'm a CNCF ambassador. I
was actually
pulled in as a CNCF ambassador last year
after applying for quite a while, and I'm
I'm super excited about being here and helping
kinda get the word out for Kubernetes technologies,
cloud native technologies, that sort of stuff. In
the past, I've worked for companies like and
and and really helped a number of of
folks just kind of learn about things through
things like TGIK and stuff like that. It
was like
it it was such a blast, and I'm
I'm really looking forward to doing more of
it. So I'm really glad to be here.
Thank you for having me on. Oh, no.
It's definitely my pleasure. You're a font of
knowledge when it comes to all of this
stuff and you've been not only just helping
me in in private for DMs whenever I
get stuck on stuff, but also you come
on and, you know, join the comments and
help us all out during the episode. So
I'm I'm soaked for today's episode.
Okay.
Let's I think we just need to dive
right in. Our first cluster is in fact,
we have a comment from Siam already. So,
Siam. Siam is the first breaker cluster 11.
So we're gonna pop the screen share on.
We're gonna use my my I think it's
my favorite tool for doing this, but teleport,
which just gives us the ability to share
a session
and pair on this in real time while
showing and sharing it with people that are
watching.
So Duffy Yeah. Yeah. Do you Oh my
goodness. Do you have it opened?
I can't believe I I don't know if
you have this word in The US. Do
you have to do you know what a
is?
Is that a Scottish word maybe?
I'm not sure. Okay. What this is? Like
a tag. Alright.
Siam is definitely is really pretty.
I wonder if that was done with, like
is that under bash, I see? I'm not
curious. Anyway, never mind. Alright. So Siam has
broken our first cluster,
and we're we're gonna do our best to
fix it. How how do you wanna start?
What have you got? I'm gonna I'm gonna
link in.
Oh, yeah. Let's confirm you can type it,
type it.
That's me. Let's see if we can see
you. I'm gonna do I'm connected and typing
in cluster 11. Do you probably click connect?
Can you go to active sessions and join
my session?
Sure. So we should have covered this. That's
my fault.
Oh, and Sam is there. So while you
join that session, Sam has told us that
each node has something different. So I'm gonna
quickly just
share
that. What we got here?
Where do I see session? Subscribe to Rawkode.
So if you look at my screen here,
you'll see there's activity
then on activity, there's active sessions.
I gotcha. Alright. Okay. Let's just see what
these other two notes say. We got
welcome Duffy. Nice.
And the last one,
Duffy rocks. Duffy does rock. Definitely. Is this
working? Do you see me saying hi? Yeah.
There's a there's a bug when you joined
that it means that I have to reload,
but I can see it. You're typing. We
are good. So
you're some linking something.
Yeah.
Normally I just export it but it's nice
to see other ways of doing this.
Oh, we're already good. See there's already four
nodes. We're finished. Yeah.
As you were on this show that we
are able to even run and get notes
at the box. So, you know, thank you
for
taking that easy on us maybe as I
am. Although we don't know what's in store,
so I shouldn't I shouldn't cut my check
engine.
Oh, it's not looking good for Rawk. They're
not happy.
See if that's okay.
So what I'm looking right now what I'm
doing right now is I'm kinda, like, doing
a a look around just to see what
we're looking at and that kind of thing.
One of the things a lot about these
sessions that I think is super interesting is
that because we're using cluster API
and cube ADM together, we can make a
bunch of assumptions about how things work. And
I wanted to, like, talk about that for
a minute because I remember, like, really being
surprised by this.
It is actually
real it would be really really
a fast fix
to do a thing like grab the the
cube ADM configuration from the config map inside
the cluster
and then leverage that to just reset all
the manifests.
So if what we were doing was, like,
erasing the clock to get this cluster back
up,
that is exactly how it would approach this.
Right? I would jump into the I would
I'd grab the the kubeadm configuration
from the cluster, and I would leverage that,
do Kube ATM reset, do Kube ATM and
hit, and just blow everything way back blow
everything back to a healthy space.
But we don't do that here. Right? Here,
we're trying to figure out how it broke.
So I kinda dig that actually.
Yeah. Definitely. It's
you know, I I I like I like
to think that it's not just about fixing
the clusters, but it's about really trying to
dig in and see what went wrong and
and understand
flags. Like, one of the really cool things
for me on this five episodes and those
six episodes is I've discovered flags on the
controllers. I had no idea that existed. And
just exploring the API and the configuration in
that way, I find super interesting.
It's just Very cool. And part fun, you
know, definitely part fun.
Okay. Let's talk about what you're typing right
now. So we ran a get node, so
we seem we had two unready and one
looked like it possibly had a taint on
it. We've ran a get pods. We're seeing
that Rawkode is
pretty unhappy. I'm assuming possibly due to the
not ready nodes.
Then you're taking a look at the pods
in the default namespace and we can see
my my workload
appear to be working, but we've got a
couple of random workloads also setting there. And
then you've run a cry control p s
as well. Yeah.
And then I was gonna make cry control
p s work real quick. So let me
just pull up the thing for that. What
should I do?
I'm not sure.
There's a thing that we did in
I swear I swear I know what I'm
doing. I've hit the wrong button.
There's a thing we did in kind, which
I think
is super handy, and I wanted to share
that with you.
See if I paste in here.
Copy.
K.
Okay. Sweet.
Rory McKeon is saying we should take off
a nuclear cluster from orbit. It's on the
way to be sure.
Exactly. But looking at would be, like, super
fast, but it wouldn't really be super educational.
So what's it what I'm doing now is
I'm setting a configuration
file in Etsy called c r I kettle
dot yaml.
And if you conf and if you populate
this, like, with with something that looks like
this, runtime endpoint, and then you point it
at the container d socket,
then you can just use c r I
kettle p s, c r kettle pods.
Could you I think there was also some
news this week as well, wasn't there? I
think that
NerdControl was donated to the container d and
cloud data foundation project.
It is. Yeah. It has been brought into
the project, but I think CI kettle is
is not going anyway. Right? C r kettle
is more like around kind of the implementation
of what the container runtime
for cube looks like. NerdKettle's
project is actually even cooler by a curious
Akahirsuda. And what he's doing is he's writing
a effectively, like, an abstraction that makes it
look and feel and work like Docker. Because,
like, I don't know if you've ever tried
to use container d directly to, like,
interact with Docker produce. Like, can you start
a container,
pull a container, mount volume, exec? There are
a bunch of those things that we would
normally use in troubleshooting that exist in c
r x kettle.
But doing those things in CTR is is
definitely a cognitive load to, like, get that
to work. And NerdKettle
looks to offset that because with NerdKettle, could
just use NerdKettle
like you would Docker.
But instead of going to the Docker obstruction,
you're going directly to container D. It's pretty
cool. Nice.
Alright. So let's see if your workload is
working. Can you you know, you wanna try
doing a proxy and seeing if your
if your website is open?
I'm actually kinda curious if if Sion broke
that first.
Let's see. We can do a port forward.
Plus we have a new sample workload now.
No longer just a boring old WordPress system.
Oh, I wanna hear more about this.
I can't remember what port I'm running on,
but we're gonna find out if it's port
80. I think I would have done port
80.
Do you have a port forward to the
control plane? Because right now you're running on
the control.
Yeah. I should know better. Okay. Let me
do that from here.
This is cluster zero 11.
I'm gonna export.
Make sure I can run get pods.
There we go. Okay.
And I've had eighty eighty on that previous
one, so I'm gonna do it again.
Let's see.
Hello?
Maybe not working?
We're not getting a connection reset on the
port forward side, which makes me think I
do have the right port.
I think my application
Ah,
let me zoom in. Oh, my.
Alright. We have do it.
Yep. Alright. We have our first clue.
Yeah. So there is something
weird. So let me explain the sample workload
then. It is a
Okay. A very simple Rust based application that
prints a video on the screen of me,
but I wanted to make sure we had
some connectivity within the clusters. I added a
quotes feature that pulls in some quotes from
people in the Kubernetes and cloud native community
and puts them on the screen for us.
That look up to the database to grab
a quote failing,
which tells me that our database service is
unhappy or potentially some networking issue within our
cluster.
So we should try more Could it be
I mean, it it can't be DNS. Right?
Like, it's never DNS.
It's never DNS. No. I I don't know
why we have that saying that's all.
But we can see
from our get pods that we ran there
that, you know, the postgres DB that we're
running in the same namespace does appear to
be running and healthy. It's passing its probes.
So, I guess we should maybe take a
look at the service before we dig into
anything else.
Oh, you're you're good. I know. Or just
let you type away. Oh.
Take a look at cube system.
Core DNS is
terminating
three days ago.
Why would it be stuck in terminating? That's
not a good sign.
Yeah. That's interesting.
But we do have two working copies of
code for DNS. That means it's not DNS,
by the way, just FYI.
That's maybe too bold a statement to make
this early on in the episode.
Fair.
Have we got too long terminating?
Interesting.
The packet cloud controller manager seems to be
dying three days as well.
Are you sourcing the completion? Yeah. There we
go.
Oh, rocket syntax.
Is that what it's called? The rocket syntax?
That's the way I that's the way I
learned about it.
So what's your hunch here? You're you've taken
a look at the pods and cube system.
You're now pulling out a conflict map. What
are you thinking?
I'm thinking that that somebody has messed with
the configuration of core DNS at least, and
it or and it might be because it's
terminating.
Terminating is super interesting. Like, that is terminating.
I wanna I wanna look at the events
for that and figure out, like, why it's
terminating, why it hasn't actually already been deleted.
So there might be also something happening with
the controller manager not doing cleanup or something
else funky happened in there.
It looks like the controller manager has restarted
a few times, and so there might be
something defined in that position. So my plan
of attack is take a look at the
core DNS configuration,
see if we can figure out what's keeping
it from working.
And then I wanna go and look at
the manifest on the as a Kubernetes manifest
directory
and check those for errors or weird stuff.
And then, you know, we'll go from there,
see if we can get things working.
Yeah. We got a comment from Jason just
saying, you know, are all the nodes up,
which we know two of them are unready
from the get nodes command area. That probably
would explain the the terminating?
I guess, if that be yeah. We can
maybe dig into that if that seems to
be the case and explain why that happened.
That's a very good point, actually. If they're
if the nodes aren't reachable, then, like, if
they've just kind of, like, gone away, then
the pod will the Kubernetes will keep those
things around almost indefinitely, which is always kind
of a surprise.
One of the things I've noticed as we
do more of these episodes as well is
that age on our conflict maps and other
things is always very misleading because it's not
edit, but the actual
usually the creation timestamp.
Yeah.
Steve Wade says, hey, Duffy.
Steve.
I know you're trying to think and stuff
here and I'm just gonna keep throwing comments
at you, but
So we're looking at the config map for
core DNS.
Let's see what we've got up here.
I mean, I really should be getting a
bit more familiar with this though, but
We do have health already Kubernetes.
Yeah. Is there a way to go in
Go
ahead.
I
was just wondering, is there a way to
know if this has been modified since the
creation?
Is this
timestamp operation update here? Does this because this
is the same as our creation timestamp, can
we assume this hasn't been touched? Is that
correct?
Creation if it's been just directly replaced, the
creation time stamp would be different than the
creation time stamp of the cluster.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm, like, at a generation with
conflict maps. Right? I don't see that here,
though. Yeah.
Looks like it's three days old.
Yeah. I And it looks like
so
03/2004.
Yeah. It looks like unless unless it was
just directly replaced three days ago. This is
probably not the thing I'm looking for. Yeah.
But it's can I see it? Can I
see it? It's not DNS?
Well, it's not this part of DNS.
That could be any number of other parts
of DNS. Yeah. This all looks fine. Okay.
So
so let's see.
Oh,
you mind if I end this all big
real quick? No. So anything that we need.
It's not big on a bunch of systems.
It will be bind utils, I believe.
And dash utils. Right? I never remember. I
always end up both trying it both ways.
Try no dash. Oh, bind nine dash utils.
There you go. Let's let's try to suggest
it to us there.
Bind nine dash util. Yeah.
The amount of times I've done apt install
deg, apt install dns utils, apt install dns
utils, apt install bing utils, like I just
I really should get better
at remembering the package. So then you go
to a fedora central system and it's all
different again.
Okay. So we're now gonna take a look
at the service. I think we're gonna describe
the postcard service to see if we actually
have any endpoints.
DNS would probably still resolve,
but
What did DNS resolve if there were no
endpoints? What would it resolve to?
And I'm not sure.
Postgres.
Oh, I typed it wrong.
That's that new keyboard of yours.
It is.
This is what I mean by rendering. Oh,
here we go. Alright. One more sec.
I wasn't doing it. There it is. Yeah.
One extra r. There we Alright.
Oh, it has endpoints. Is it?
Yeah.
I think I do think it's gonna be
DNS. So what I was gonna do was
If let's see if built in DNS is
broken.
Sam
asks, who's eating popcorn?
I'm gonna ask him that's rhetorical question and
you're sitting there giggling away. Watch
we
know that Jason is giggling. Thanks, Jason. Thanks
for the support, mate.
What then?
Just Jason, the timbers laughing.
That's all.
Error from server pods bash is forbidden. Post
service check. Eight eight eight check. Oh, nice.
Alright. Okay. So what what happened there? Okay.
We've tried to run a bash image and
and
we couldn't create a resource. Ah,
nice.
Very nice. So this is gonna be an
a p this is gonna be an admission
control
thing.
So you're opening the manifest because you want
to know if it's dynamic or if it's
a static admission controller. Is that right?
Yeah. Yeah. I'm looking at the admission controller
flags and also any other configuration in admission
to see what's been turned on. Looks like
note our back is here, but there is
an admission control config
file, s e kubernetes demo admission dot JSON.
Yeah. We is
let's see. Kubernetes.
I don't see I don't see how this
could mount.
It's interesting. So I bet you it's just
erroring out because it's not present.
Let's see Kubernetes demo admission control. Let's take
a look at it anyway. Yeah. Why not?
What has he done to us?
Can we find out?
Alright.
Here we're applying some certificates.
We have a service check eight eight eight
check image,
which is probably gonna be a a thing
running inside of
I mean, somehow, it's gonna have to resolve
this, but it doesn't it doesn't look like
it likely is. So a quick way to
resolve this particular problem and move past it
would be for us just to remove this
admission controller because it wasn't part of our
original cluster.
So can I just clarify can
you explain something to me here? Okay. So
there was an admission controller JSON flag that
pointed to this JSON file, which points to
a kube config file with some parameters.
Oh, my teleporter. Oh, there's a disconnect. Oh,
yeah. I think it's just because you're oh,
you open then. I thought my teleporter has
crashed, but we're good. Oh, no.
But I'm
I wanted to I wanted to look at
the the API server's configuration so we could
look at what's happening in here. Right? So
what I was pointing out before or what
I was curious was whether the the file
was actually mounted into the into the manifest
because remember the API server is gonna be
running as a static pod. So all of
the resources that that static pod needs have
to be mounted in just like you'd mount
anything else into a container.
Yeah. So because if we go up here
to the admission line
where it says admission control config file,
this this line is pointing at that configuration
file, which kicks off the whole
set of things that allow the API server
to interact with that admission webhook and see
if it could get and and and see
if the image that we're pulling is allowed
or disallowed.
I don't know what Siam put in the
allow list or the denial list. It might
still be in that demo
directory somewhere, and we'll look at that a
little bit more here in just a minute.
But I think for now, what I wanna
do is drop this line. Yeah. Agreed. And
then just down here on enable
admission
plugins.
Uh-huh. Can you see the The image policy
webhook on the end?
And then That's the thing that tells it
that's the it's like a two parter in
this particular admission control plug in. Right? The
first part is to enable the image policy
webhook, which tells the API server we have
a thing that is just gonna do image
policy validation,
whether it's allowed or denied. And then the
configuration file tells it where to go find
that thing and how to ask it.
It's that.
I know. Do you know what node restriction
does? This is so cool.
It is really cool. Yeah. Go for it.
Let's let's see here. What does it do?
What node restriction does is it
it's responsible for
so
when I first started playing with Kubernetes,
typically, what we what people would do is
they would, like, give every node, like, almost
the same certificate. Right? The same identity certificate.
And all of the nodes are represented by
a group called system nodes, and you would
apply permissions
from to that system nodes object. That means
that any node in the cluster effectively was
like god mode. It could
read anything inside the cluster. It could do
anything with its own credential. It was effectively
unlimited. Right? As long so if you could
exploit the underlying node, you could easily take
over the cluster because that credential that the
node had, that was a high value credential.
What node restriction does
is it
enforces that a node, as identified by its
host
or by its by its node name
can only access those resources
that are attributed
to that node.
Right? So if you were to try and
do KubeKitle get secrets all in fact, we
let's just try this out real quick. It'll
be really cool. Get secrets
dash.
Man.
Working on it. I'm gonna get it.
Apple a
dash dash
config.
This
is node restriction.
This is what that admission plugin is doing.
Without that admission plugin, then all of the
secrets would have just flushed to the disc
would sort of flush to the screen.
Ah. Pretty cool. Yeah. That is cool. Okay.
Yeah. It's like a really nice view.
For a little while.
I've seen that at mission yeah. That mission
controller on a couple of episodes now. I
wasn't sure if it was evil from one
of the breakers or part of the setup,
and I just kind of ignored it. So
I'm glad you've taken the time to explain
that.
Definitely a good thing.
One of the other things but you can
do things like get nodes. You can do
things like other you can there are a
bunch of other, like, more generic
cluster wide commands that you can still do
with that credential.
So if you were a if you were
a
an attacker and you only had, like, a
user specific or namespace specific credential, this is
a way that you could escalate your privilege
to have a cluster wide
read
certificate if you took over the node. So
interesting stuff. Nice. Anyway, so
Okay. So we've removed that from
our API server. Does does
that mean you should now be able to
run that batch image, and is that still
our our plan going forward?
That's still my plan going forward. Okay.
What?
We go deeper.
Disable pod, check for labels, validation errors. So
I am has disabled
pod creation on your cluster. Rule, check for
labels.
Failed at pass. Metadata labels app. So that
means that we have
yes. PRD.
Oh, nice. Oh, Sam.
What what what do you see? Oh, I
see chaos glitch. I would just like to
I would just like to point these things
out.
Yeah. Go for it.
Wow.
Oh, that's beautiful.
Look at it. Okay. So what I just
ran here was I did keep getting CRD,
which is because I know that it's not
gonna be an admission anymore. Right? The admission
plug in pieces, we've effectively taken care of.
So anything else that's gonna eat our lunch
is gonna be deployed into inside the cluster,
And those things that are deployed inside the
cluster are almost always gonna have to be
registered with the cluster for them to work.
There's a couple of different ways that we
can see those things or that that Kubernetes
can be extended
to be able to support those things. Like,
one of them is custom resource definitions.
Right? And
and that's what I'm listing here is kubectl
get cluster resource definitions. Let's me see, you
know, what is the other stuff that is
available inside of this cluster that I could
use
or that has been registered with the cluster?
And what we see
is a bunch of good stuff. Right? We
see a bunch of, like, custom resource definitions
that end in chaosmesh.org.
We see that Caverno is enabled, which is
probably the thing that is currently blocking us.
Yep.
And we but we also see that there
has been some goosery.
You know? I use that term goosery
to describe what has hap stress chaos.
That's probably the best one word thing ever,
stress chaos. Stress chaos. Yes.
Also really good. Alright.
So
good old.
Yeah. And this
so likely, he deployed
this into something. Right? So we have a
couple of different namespaces here. We have Caverno.
You get all get NS
dash r. It's like get Dash
oh,
A Dash N.
Would you like me to do some typing?
And now the thing that's giving me is
the dashes. I gotta figure out how to
remap that.
What?
Oh.
Oh, you did, like, get dash a instead
of pods. I
think it's dash all that I wanted.
Well, no. Because you're specifying the namespace with
dash and Kiverno. You've not set a resource.
I'm assuming you want pods.
Oh, you wanted actually all. Okay.
Alright. So we have our service running.
We have a deployment.
How does convert will get
populated?
Get all
get
API resources.
Okay. So we're gonna have cluster policies, which
are CPOLs.
Yep. We're gonna have cluster report change requests.
We're gonna have generate requests. I'm looking probably
for CPauls.
So
you can all get
CPaul dash
We'll take a look at it.
Yeah. I think that disabled port policy is
definitely something we wanna
take a look at.
Alright.
What do we got here? We have
background tool, rules match, resource kind for pods,
check for labels.
Validate data. The message is this.
Match resources. Damon sets deployments jobs, stateful sets.
Oh, I'm tempted to do a replica set
just to mess them up because it didn't
get caught.
And then
disabled
for that.
Blocked cron jobs.
I think replica replica set was the only
one he forgot.
Looks like
Yeah. I think But for our purposes
but
I was gonna say, I guess, we just
wanna delete this terrible policy.
Right?
That's what I wanna see.
Like, is there a way
those match
validation failure action. Probably something that we could
edit to make it approve or something or
ignore.
No.
What's the subject again?
It's a c poll cluster policy. Yeah.
Hey.
Alright.
I love when people actually do this. It's
not it's not everyone that does it today,
but it's really cool.
So the explain command allow us to get
the documentation
on the open API definition for the policy,
if I'm not mistaken. Is that close enough?
Yeah.
Like,
you can't do it now. It didn't used
to be that you could do it, but
you can do it now, which is very
cool.
So are you looking for a way to
allow this to fail rather than deleting it
just because you're being nice, or you wanna
be a bit more methodological?
Okay. There's that word I can never see
on this team.
Methodo methodological.
It's a good word. It is a good
word. I can tell you. Yeah.
What I'm wondering is oh, I mean, let's
just we could try nuking it, but I
was wondering if we just turn it into
something that will just allow us to do
all the things rather than deny us to
do all the things, whether we could just
leave it in place and keep going and
till we can play with it later. But
let's let's try and nuke again. Let's see
what happens.
Yeah. But there was only one policy. I
didn't see a policy to block the deletion
of a policy, which would be a nice
trick in itself. So
That would be admission. Or, I mean, I
guess you could use OPA or something.
C all dash
I think it was called disable pod.
Disable hyphen pod.
Oh, the sledgehammer approach.
Terminates.
It's my favorite technique.
And it's gone. Boom. Okay.
Alright. Let's see if we can get in
there.
Ta da. Oh. Oh, I thought I thought
it was that
yeah.
Oh. No.
No. That's probably okay. It's probably gonna just
take look at Maybe.
No. I think we've got a network in
issue. The bash image shouldn't take that long.
Right?
Probably not.
But we did see some other stuff, didn't
we? Like we saw the chaos thing. So
I wonder if we're
Yeah. There is the litmus kiosk deployed to
our cluster. We got two nodes in a
not ready state, which I'm assuming could be
a side effect of this litmus stuff that's
running.
I know that the litmus stuff has labels.
I think that opt you in.
And what I'm wondering
is whether
failure to me. I don't see any labels
there. No. I don't see anything. KLC.
No.
But not ready. Not ready. Not ready. That's
probably not a good thing.
So what what makes Kubernetes
return are not ready when you're doing the
get notes? What what does it consider a
ready note?
Do you know?
Usually, ready ready oh, what's that?
So ready notes are really about
the configuration of the cubelet. Right? So if
you this in the fact, you can even
see to some degree, like, why why it's
ready or not ready. So piddle
five node.
See worker
a
t.
So ready in this case,
looks like requests.
The method's nothing being used here.
So this is a big part of ready
right here. Right? Network unavailable, false. Memory pressure,
unknown.
Keyboard has stopped posting node status, which means
that this node has just kind of,
you know, withered off into the into into
the into the history books. It's not connect
it's no longer reporting in. So we have
to go look at why that node's not
reporting in.
Right? So in this case, ready means that.
But ready could mean any of these things.
And with, like, some of the more recent
stuff in cube,
Kubernetes now has the way or
or this is now extensible. You could have
things like, you know, node problem detector indicate
whether a node is ready or not ready
as well and kind of and and extend
that. But for the most part, if you
look at this condition status here, that's gonna
tell you what not ready means.
So let's go jump into our other nodes
and see what we see. Do you wanna
pop open a connect a connection, or shall
I? Yeah. You can do it. I'll just
join. It's all good.
Okay.
Click it all.
I'm gonna go to Target first.
Get notes.
I'm gonna jump into 7694F.
Let's see.
Servers
7694F.
Subscribe to
Rawkode.
Do you see that?
Yeah. Thanks, Sam.
Appreciate the assist.
Alright. So we done a system control status
on the Kiplit.
It looks like it's loaded,
but not running. That's what I'll be. That's
yeah. We can see it's an activating
auto restart seven seconds. So
keep it.
Not happy.
Exception.
Yeah. Let me figure out the journal logs
here.
Dash flu?
Yeah.
Interesting.
What is going on here?
So it looks like Object. Yeah. Words. The
Kubelet config
object API version missing.
Nice.
K.
Wirelib kubelet config dot YAML. That's actually a
super handy error.
Yeah. If only all other messages were itself,
what was that? Look at the typo.
Cheeky Siam.
Do you see it?
Yeah. I'm trying to get over to it.
It's a I I.
What's a I I? Yeah. There you go.
Yeah. RP.
And while I'm in here, I already see
something that looks a bit mischievous, but our
client c a file five
lines down is c a two dot c
r t. I wonder if that's either been
renamed or
it was just thrown around them too in
there too.
Confused. It is surprising. I think Kubernetes p
k I c a two.
Not even leaving them. Look at that.
See, that's there. There we go. Yes,
I am. We got it.
You've dropped into recording mode.
That's how I roll. You know, I like
that.
1722076Of10.
Yeah. That's correct. For for k Q D
N S.
I have the address in green, then we
know.
Else looks pretty okay. This is actually one
of the things that always trips me out.
You see this line right here? Static PodPass?
Yeah.
This means that with the cube ADM based
cluster,
static pods work on any node.
Isn't that interesting?
They should only have to work on the
control plane nodes. There was an issue open
for this, but never got really resolved.
I didn't know that. So on a worker
node, I could create that directory, add the
config and then just run whatever workloads I
want.
Yep.
One of our friends and my current colleague,
Dan Fennerin discovered that if you put the
namespace into static manifest,
that namespace doesn't exist, it will still run
the pod and it's invisible to keep control
commands, which I think is ridiculous.
That should that shouldn't be a thing. And
and and and I have been up to
some pretty good onks that way.
That is
keep it.
Yeah.
Looks happy.
But I'm just gonna jump over to our
under other tab and run our get nodes
and yeah. That that one is back and
happy.
Alright. Let's jump over to number PMC q
h. PMC
q H. I'm gonna start it and he'll
join or Yeah. Yeah. Go for it.
Okay.
Welcome, Duffy.
I
I feel welcome, Flanagan.
Alright. Let's see what we got here. It
does say not ready schedule and disabled, which
makes me think the Kubelet oh, no. It's
not gonna be okay because I can see
it restarting already. I thought we make an
okay Kubelet with something that should get on,
but not the case. We have another exception.
Okay. It'll minus
u.
Keep it.
The u is for unit, l is for
wrap lines, f is for follow.
Yeah. I tend to do Do remember? X
e dash u. I don't know why I
separate them though. I feel like I feel
really silly now that I didn't think of
that, so I I'm stealing this from you.
And I always used to do no pager
for the rap lines, so that dash l
is awesome. That's probably the best thing I've
learned today.
Well, that and the other thing you taught
me with Chrome, which is I guess you
could Oh, yeah. The trick is self sign
certs. This is unsafe. Good trick.
Yeah. I'll let you read the logs and
when I explain that. Like teleport as running
with self signed certificates and Chrome I just
assumed that let me do that because it
was trying to be secure and then Duffy
taught me that if I just type this
as unsafe.
Yeah. This is unsafe
into the browser. It loads it anyway.
It's a awesome little trick.
I think our problem.
Right here. Container d is not run. In
fact, no, the path to the socket is
wrong.
You see there's missing a k.
My face is almost covering it, but hopefully
people can see that. Yeah.
Where is that system?
I
don't
see system the
cubelet service d 10 cubic d m config.
Yeah. Let's see. System.
System.
Kubelet.
Barlet, Kubit, Kubit config dot emo.
I really wish there was an easier way
to work through all the different environment fails.
There are too many of them, but yeah.
I mean, like,
a bunch to one place in
violin kubeletconfig.yaml
has been a boon for sure.
But I think what I'm looking for is
this one.
Violet kubelet kubelet mflags.env.
So c d
Violet kubelet.
There it is. There it is.
Another trick. Boink.
Oh. Oopsie. I'm not supposed to make it
worse. Come on. Fix it. Alright. Yeah. Yeah.
I've lost track of it a bit of
times. I've made a cluster worse than this
show.
Alright. Let's see. Let me jump over.
I'm trying to watch.
Done that weird thing.
Online again.
It's now ready, but scheduling is disabled. So
I'm assuming it's got some sort of
tint on it.
Oh, you just corded. Oh, let's go. I'll
cord and check.
Okay. I'm gonna jump back over to that.
How should we do kettle?
P m c a p m c q
h.
Worker.
P m c q h.
It notes.
There.
You You wanna run a get pods all
and see if all those random broken things
are
coming back to life? Those dashes are causing
me I know they're really getting
I know. We still get a lot of
no. Maybe. Maybe it's getting better. Still
well, it's looking pretty good.
I think they're running.
Let's take a look at your test app
again,
if you don't mind.
Yep. Let me reload.
I really need to speak to the Teleport
team and get that fixed. So let's see.
Get pods.
Or forward.
It's not changed as it nope.
Get a refresh on that guy.
Yeah. It's
but I think it's gonna time out again
on us. So we're still unable to speak
to
Postgres.
Connections. Okay. Yeah. I think it's gonna time
out on us.
Alright. There we go. So we're still gonna
there was something weird going on here.
Okay.
Keep it all. But we do have all
the keyplets online.
Let's progress.
What's your what are you thinking at the
moment?
I am actually curious how it's configured. Like,
you know, if there's is DNS busted or
anything else like that? The other thing I'm
thinking about is just trying to see if
I can resolve DNS from inside there to
see if that's a see if there's a
real problem.
Well, That's the bug. But where control run
you did for the bash part is it's
still pending,
which is something
I think we need to fix in order
to get the connect to have it even
on the cluster working.
Sure.
Yeah. That's not good.
Yeah. You know what I think is happening?
Go for it.
I'm curious.
Yep. We still haven't figured out what he
was doing with all the chaos stuff.
Oh, yeah. Should we just delete all that
chaos stuff? Surely that's just there to trip
us up.
Although if it has caused chaos deleting, that
may not be the best approach.
We probably wanted to undo the chaos.
So controller manager is looking okay.
I think we should take a look in
the the litmus name space then that was
created. We both know Litmus Chaos is a
CNC project,
Chaos Monkey sales thing.
Sam is a way to fetch another popcorn.
We do have the chaos operator running.
We have chaos operator metrics running.
We have a deployment.
Should we just nuke it? Let's just nuke
it. Let's just nuke it. Nothing
good ever came from running chaos there. It's
actually kind of an interesting thing. I wanna
find out my reasoning here. Like, in the
deployment, if we have a pod that's running
that is the chaos operator, then it's the
chaos operator that's eating our lunch. Right? It's
actively finding our lunch and eating it. But
if we
disable that pod, then it can no longer
do that thing. Right? So when I'm when
I'm deleting that deployment,
I should be able to completely disable the
chaos operator from doing what it's what it
was doing before.
Unless it's running as a static pod somewhere,
in which case, I will be so so
pleasantly surprised, I am. I can't even really
put it into words. But this is the
reason why I'm totally done with turning this
off in this case.
Let's see what happens.
Bye bye, KS.
Hold on. No reset. Perfect. I'm
gonna reload my app. Do we think that
the chaos just disappearing is gonna fix I
don't The bash one is still pending. Should
we maybe describe that?
I wanna see what's happening. Get all
bash.
Yeah. Still says pending.
Not
very useful.
So it's like maybe the schedule is not
there.
Yeah. Strange that we're getting
nothing.
Bet if there's another table in one of
the in the scheduler manifest or something.
No. It looks like it's there.
It's restarted a few times. Yeah.
So in another window, I have, like, a
kind cluster stood up because kind is also
KubeTM based,
and that can help me, like, understand what
the configuration looks like for a working scheduler.
Mhmm.
Employment.
I'm curious about looking at that real quick.
Keeps scheduler 124. Looks right like the right
image.
I don't see anything particularly
bad about this scheduler. Looks okay.
What I wonder is
there is a way to extend the scheduler.
Big maps.
That's in
two system.
But I don't see anything extending it.
What if we did keep it off?
Create
deployment
test.
And then flag image.
What you talking about?
Get off.
Yeah. I'm not sure.
Although I don't often bust a a create
deployment to be fair. Normally, just use a
kib control run.
It's different.
I wonder if I text it or something.
It
worked.
I created the replica set.
Yeah. I'm sure we Yeah. Nothing to plug
yet.
Pending.
Not being scheduled, though. The scheduler is definitely
not doing the same.
Our problem is the scheduler. Shall we take
a look at the scheduler logs?
Oh, okay. Before I do this,
I wanna make a I wanna make a
bet that it's that it's permissions.
Oh.
K. So the scheduler
oh, look at the port number on that.
Yeah. There we go.
Feather, Siam. Wow.
That's pretty.
Okay. Where is that configured?
Oh,
that is configured here.
Oh, you just jumped at the manifest directory.
I don't know if you meant that. No.
I did.
Oh, scheduled. Ah, okay.
So in the in yes.
So good. So good. So good, Saya.
You should find one to say.
Alright. Let's run that get pods.
The scheduler oh, well. When we change the
configs of the scheduler, do we need to
restart up pods? Yeah.
That's the thing. Right? Like, that's the thing
about about most of the thing most most
things in app in the application space. Nothing
unless it's implemented specifically,
nothing's gonna trigger to the fact that the
file system has changed.
So move
manifest
to
here.
There's
a cool trick last week that someone pointed
out that you can just touch the fail
in order to restart it even.
It was Jason. I learned that last week.
I did not know that last I did
not know that.
Jason just popped up with a comment. Hey.
We need to restart that.
Yeah. Was a good trick. I like that
one.
In fact, he's already jumped in. That would
work well.
Yeah. That was a great thing I learned
last week. I love that one.
Wonder if there's like another typo in
so that's obvious. There we go.
Hey, yo. Back in I
think we're I think we have I think
we have this cluster.
Well, no. We don't have a database connectivity
yet.
Still not resolved our DNS issue.
But we are getting short on time.
Oh, and the pods aren't creating either. Hopefully,
that's just Hey, Ted, puppy. Let's go. Pull
it.
I mean, I know I'm impatient.
I think we're gonna have to describe that.
Yeah. That's not right.
That is scheduled, but unable to run.
Alright. Well, let's see what this has been
associated
with.
This is on Worker
7 6 9 4 F.
Oh,
let's see here. Docker library bash failed to
do request.
Dial TCP lookup register
on 1477520720.
What is that? Is that a DNS name
that you actually know?
That is 14775
is the facility or region that I have
deployed this to.
So no.
Okay. So I'm gonna jump back over to
I'm gonna jump back over to
this guy, this node here,
which is the 7694F
node. And I already still have my session
open, I think.
Oh, yep. I'm on it. There you go.
Okay. Girlgoogle.com.
I don't know what this is supposed to
be. Let's just throw 8.8.8.a
in there.
Let's get it Well, let's
see if it works from the
curl google.com.
I think it works from here. K. Let's
see. Resolve.com.
Which session are you on?
I just went back to the master real
quick just to look at this resolve.com.
I'm gonna compare. So 207207207208.
Oh, yeah. He's taking the numbers off the
end.
Oh,
alright.
It's obvious you know, it's it's a it's
death by a thousand cuts.
Seven.
Alright. And then I'm gonna go back to
them. I'm gonna do curl
google.com.
Hey.
I'm gonna jump back to that master.
Yep.
You can we'll get pods.
Ash is running. Test is still kinda mostly
unhappy.
Oh, that yeah.
I send back off so it might just
need to kick.
Mostly to
to get all described
pod.
Actually, pulled it. Yeah.
Okay.
There we go.
Now what does it look like for the
database?
Nugget.
So
I think that's gonna say that again.
Alright.
K. K.
Should we jump inside of the
container,
the custard container Yeah. And try and execute
a few commands?
Okay.
You may wanna just check that's working.
That that exists, I mean.
Do you have a script in here that
does, like, the testing?
No. I'm afraid not.
You're gonna have to do an laptop there,
I think, on that.
We have no connectivity.
Wait a minute. That doesn't look right. You
said it was something else before. Oh, wait.
Is it?
+1 722026010
is yeah. That is right. Yeah. That's good.
Okay.
Right?
Yeah.
Yeah. That's right.
You can get all Yeah. Get get services.
Cache and system.
Yeah. There we go. Yeah. That's okay.
Do wanna describe it? Make sure we got
endpoints.
Right.
K. I'm gonna pull another batch trick.
Nice.
It has in punch too. Okay. That looks
good.
So our exec
interesting.
So
when we're in here catcresolve.com.
20 6 0 ten.
Curl Google
It feels like a network policy to me.
You're probably right because you're using Cilium.
Good call, David.
I get them right once in a blue
moon, so hopefully.
Hopefully, today's my day.
No. Well,
that must maybe it's a misleading name. I
don't think that's a deny ingress.
Let's just delete it.
Alright. I'm gonna jump over to my app.
Look at that.
That's a nice catch.
May your bag be bountiful and your success
great. PS, you're very smart and hot. Signs,
Steven Augustine. And
here's my lovely video for y'all.
Found us that we got time. We need
to fix this.
There we go.
Should we deploy the update?
Yeah. Good.
Image
version two.
I don't have an alias key. I have
no point in that now.
We have our new version coming. Let's pop
over here and get a new port forward.
I think we fixed everything,
hopefully.
Image isn't too big. It should be real
quick.
Very cool.
Thank you, Sam. That was fun.
There we go. We have our new
container
port forward
this one
and make sure our upgrade
worked.
I think it's just not ready yet.
There we go.
And if the video doesn't load, I think
that's just my
my application.
Fight for your limits and sure enough they're
yours by Duffy's mom. It's true. I love
that statement. One of my favorites. Right. My
knowledge is the best knowledge.
Thank you, Siam. That was awesome.
We're not gonna get my dance in video
because clearly I've messed up v two of
the image, but the quote worked. We have
our connectivity. We did deploy our update.
We are ready for cluster 13.
You happy? I do. Good. Good. Right.
I'm happy.
Thank you, Sam. That was good fun.
Let's get that closed.
So I don't make because I've got a
very bad habit of going to the wrong
cluster.
Alright. 0 13.
Export to config and then we'll come over
here. Okay. Let's jump onto the control point.
So this cluster, I kinda left as a
little bit of a surprise for you.
Alright. Alright. We we had
two returning breakers,
former colleagues of yours. Can you guess who
that would be?
Oh, no.
It is Jason
Was it and Jason did that be it?
It is Dan and Jason. They decided to
put a little special together for you.
You know? So
feel like I feel like I feel like
I'm opening a love letter here right now.
You know? Like,
that
makes me feel awesome.
Alright. So maketheyear.com.
Oh, cool. Okay. I'll be back at at
just one second. Apologies.
Alright.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
Oh, it's not a good sign.
Sorry about that.
Sorry.
Okay.
Did we have an API server, or is
that too much to ask?
We I think that is too much to
ask. +1 6849.
8 40 9. Alright. Well, that's the first
test I wanted to look at. K.
Which line again so I can remember what
it is?
Jason's saying no API server. I didn't expect
her to be one, to be fair. But,
you know, I can remain a little bit
hopeful at time.
See you at kettle.
Yes.
Oh my. Oh.
Oh. Oh. Oh my.
A little sparse there, isn't it?
Yeah. It's looking a little anorectic. It's true.
Kubernetes manifests.
They're like
Interesting. When you go when you go to,
like when you're tab completing and you realize
that there's more to a word than you
think there is,
you know you know that feeling? Yeah. I'm
having a feeling.
Well,
let's let's see what the left is in
the Oh.
Not working.
Unless
I'm just gonna take a quick peek at
these Mhmm. Because it
that's,
I think, probably a good idea.
Just take a quick little look here. Okay?
Nope. That's all. Okay. Okay. Looks normal.
Maybe Suspiciously.
So
Oh, even SED is gone.
Yeah.
It's a good sign. Okay.
Totally gross.
Also oh,
what?
Does that look okay? Does that look bad?
I mean, I don't think the SED, the
daemon, actually generates a thing that's called walled
up broken. I'm just putting it out there.
You know? Oh, yeah. Like, we be recovering
some STD stuff here.
I need to start adding rules. No break
in STD either
because Violet etcd. Violet etcd.
2381.
'20 '3 '80 '1.
'20 '3 '70 '9.
They don't it doesn't look like they've been
too mean to me here. Like, this all
looks right to me.
So what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna start by doing this. Move
to FTD.
Hold
on. What's that?
Okay.
Slash.
Should we
run like a PS or something first? Just
because maybe they are running and
No. Because cry control would show us down
at the lowest level. Right? There's no way
to hide stuff from a cry control.
Well, there is. Oh. But, you you have
you gotta be a little more creative. I
I don't think they did that. I don't
think they would do that per se. Okay.
I trust you.
Oh, we got a fairly amazing trying to
pop up there.
Ready.
It's a good sign.
Right.
Okay. That's a
reasonably
good sign.
Okay.
The next thing I'm gonna do,
I'm gonna move the API server over there.
So you're just moving things back one by
one because you don't trust these two. Right?
I don't know what you're talking about. Trust
these I trust these guys with my life.
Or at least the life of my pets.
I guess it could take a little bit
longer for the API server, but
let's see.
Oh, yeah. There we go.
So when we do a a cry control
get pods there and it says state ready,
that's
just as far as the container goes and
not
readiness program for that because it's not it's
not aware of that level. Right?
Yeah. So it's like, pods shows you the
sandbox
and PS shows you the process.
Okay.
Oh, SCD did in fact bounce on this.
Oh,
yeah. Perfect.
Okay. So I'm gonna move h m s
to a back. Or
should we delete that broken file?
Maybe that's causing us easy to filter initialize.
Maybe it's just like a random text file
that's got some, you know, profanity in it
or something.
I
like I like where you read that, but
I wanna
see.
I don't know. Yes.
That's a
I wanna see if
you can grab the logs from this puppy.
Get all
bugs.
I guess you could also go to
our log containers as well. I don't know.
Cray control could do that too. That's cool.
We got a
oh, okay. Permission based. Yeah.
Doesn't look bad.
You see anything that's
suspicious?
Looks okay to me. Hold Open
bar, let it see the member snap.
Is it not is it not running as
a root?
We got a security contact. Is that what
you're looking for?
What I was wondering was, like, if it
was mounted read only or something. It
doesn't look like it was.
It looks fine.
And it keeps saying My low pitch. In
my weird high pitched voice because I have
no idea.
See that error message There
it is.
Now open database, Violet etcd member snap DB.
Operation
not permitted.
Open
Snap t p. So let's do a look
at Snap t p.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Check her.
We wanna see if there's any weird attributes
on the file that would Flown away
this is what they've done.
I can't even remember what the syntax is
to look at the permissions that we're seeing.
Hold on.
Jason's left his very sneaky comment there. There
are more to permissions
than the files. Yeah.
Shutter.
How do I
but I wanna see the permissions.
LSetter.
That's what it is.
I think we need the translator.
You dirty dog.
Can you explain that to me?
Hold on.
That's beautiful. So
in the file in
the attributes file system attributes. Right? It's a
thing. It's like a security feature for the
underlying because in in Linux, everything is a
file. So you can actually mark a file
immutable.
And if you mark that file immutable with
its attributes, then that means that nothing can
effectively mutate it.
What's neat about permissions here is that we're
so used to looking at, like, whether I'm
allowed to do a thing, not think of
the think of, like, attributes more like the
authorization
rather than the authentication.
Like, I'm authenticated to do the thing. I
have readwrite. I'm good. I can I've they
it knows me. I'm rude. I'm a I'm
good. But
Chatter says,
but no matter who you are, you cannot
do that. Right? So it's, basically setting
setting the permission to block it. So
I want to disable minus
I, I think.
Should we just set a a man change
adder and see if it lists the different
attributes?
Would that work? I think I want shatter
minus I.
No man d b. Oh, well. Never mind.
So that I is an immutable flag and
we think that we've removed that and now
it should start when it restarts
correctly.
Yeah. That was two minutes ago, so we
might just have to
Oh, I'm looking at a one.
Yeah. Exit two minutes ago.
Does that mean the touch didn't work?
Or did we move it back out of
the directory and into the
I have not moved it out of the
directory. It is right where it's supposed to
be.
I know this works, though.
Yeah. Don't think you moved it. You only
put one dot instead of two.
You see the HDD pod drop.
It goes. I believe STD back into manifest.
Yeah. There's conversations in the chat right now
about SE Linus and AppArmor.
Yeah.
I'm not dealing with that.
There's no one else to ban things.
Houston knows how I feel about AppArmor, so
that would be that would be particularly cruel.
I feel like I'm getting some lag here.
See where I cut all.
Well, we don't know if they haven't done
other stuff to this machine. I wouldn't be
surprised if there was something timed
inappropriately.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
Yeah. That's not coming back.
Oh, look at the load average. Hello.
Dang.
We better stop that quick before we
there's access to this host.
Key swap d.
What was your thought process in running mount
there?
I was trying to see if we could
do LS swap and see if we have
it. But I don't remember what the trick
is, so, like,
swap. We could just just swap off all.
I think it's the dash dash all.
So in the swap.
So
you're not using a top memory.
We
do you see the cubelet freaking out? Yeah.
The cubelet. Interesting.
You wanna try a p s a u
x and get a fill path on that
k swap d just in case it's just
particular just in case it's named that way,
but not actually.
Or you think it's cubelet?
I'm just gonna take the cubelet out for
now because it's freaking out. So I wanna,
like, try and reduce the load.
If the cubelet's taking up so much juice,
then maybe that'll help us a little bit.
There we go.
Let's get that. Nope.
Nope.
That's not what I wanted.
Message.
Secret part of memory process called API server.
That's because the cubit died, and that's okay.
You know what? I'm gonna move
FS
API server.
I'm gonna move the API server back out
of here.
Because I don't know for sure if there's
not something else happening. I haven't looked at
the image or anything.
Okay.
CTL.
So I'll do a few.
And that minus.
Gotta really find a gotta really find a
way to do that.
Choice of a new keyboard.
Right?
Yeah.
We all do it.
Alright. Let's see what the keyboard I'll say
then.
Memory, c group out of memory error.
Total VM.
Oh, they messed with the c groups.
I think my teleport has
it's not crashes. It's very slow.
Yeah.
Okay.
So whenever we start the Kubelet, the or
the API server,
bad things are happening.
Yeah.
Also see so a secret out of error
message out of memory error.
That looks okay. A little bit in the
file. In the unit file, though. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm pulling up a command that should
give us the ability to see, like, what
the top
consuming c groups are
and see if there's maybe a c group
that has been started up in another namespace
or some other way.
Does that say that we only have 1.6
gig of memory?
It does. Oh, I just got kicked out.
Boink.
Hold on.
Oh, this machine's definitely slowing down again.
Is it restarting or
1869999.
There's something weird with the machine.
We got 62 gig of
RAM, but we've only got one available.
Perfect.
Oh, Jason's commenting. What does three dash h
show? What's the h channel and no g
and m?
Human readable. I can't even I can't even
get back in right now.
We've only 1.1 giga RAM available to the
machine.
But that means that
So how is it to restrict the avail
memory of it? But that would have to
be a kernel boot arg, or is there
another way of doing that?
You could do cat
cat
proc c m d line
and see if something was defined there.
No. It's okay. Yeah.
Think it's gonna be
the dev cat. Something is the be the
way that Sorry. I need to go.
I think it'll be something in
the way the c groups
are configured. Like, the c group itself has
been manipulated for the root c group.
Now is that root c group gonna be
process one?
Like, can we see it by
broadening around it? Yeah.
I can make the cat Let's take a
look.
I
think I'm gonna need some help from well,
Dan, of course, you know,
this is probably gonna be a thing that
is a little bit on the edge of
my experience. So somewhere there
But you can modify the kernel through the
SAS interface. Right? Is there a way for
us to pull something out of here?
It would probably be under
Secret. Yeah. Under secret.
Maybe not. Features.
Maybe it's m m. Oh, you think it's
secret features. Hold on. Alright.
It's really painful to type.
I can't even get in though. Jason has
said We even get in. Not secret related.
So there must be another way to restrict
the memory on this device. They haven't modified
the kernel bit parameters.
We got a comment in chat, proc mem
info. Let's check that out.
Oh,
I got booted out.
Hey. When you invited me, what username did
you give me?
Your Twitter handle.
Okay.
Which I'm not sure how to pronounce. Is
it Maui lion? Maui? How would you say
it? Maui.
Maui likes the island I grew up on.
Maui.
Lion likes the big cat. Maui lion. Maui
lion. Got it.
Alright. We're we're we're gonna have to
gotta handle this memory thing because
otherwise debugging this cluster is not gonna
My intuition is telling me that they they
did something to, like, the root c group
that limited
the available memory to the root c group,
the top one.
What I think has happened. It's told us
it's not c group. Well,
I can't even get back in. So there's
that. Yeah. I'm gonna try and SSH from
my terminal and see if that helps. There
is a run time tunable.
Yeah. We may have to pull up Google.
Alright. Okay.
How Unclaimed.
What if you do cat proc mem info?
Anything?
Oh, that's what I tried to do before.
It completely
died on me.
VM allocated.
No. That looks
I mean, unless I'm missing something, this is
all looking
I think our problem our consists is in
another castle. That's what I think.
So he says it's a runtime tunable.
Let's take a look at the configuration of
container d.
Can we do system CTL? But my host
is showing that we don't have memory available.
I don't think that's his
container d. Right? Like
Well, everything is in a namespace. Right? So
it's gonna be I mean but you just
said so, like, we have two options. Either
we're missing something in the way that
c groups themselves are configured
at the kernel layer,
and we need to go chase that down
and find out where that is.
Or
runtime wise, there's something messing us up.
So
my intuition tells me that it like, I
want this to be something where they configured
the root c group, limited the amount of
memory available to it.
You can also you can tune the kernel
virtual memory.
Kernel virtual memory.
Oh, it's SPM. Okay. So
I'm impressed.
Tuning virtual memory.
Can you take a look at
sysctl
dash a pipe grip?
Let's
see. What do I wanna see?
Mem to dash a just in case. Yeah?
Maybe that's It's probably VM.
I wanna see VM min three k bytes.
Let's try VM instead of mem. Maybe there's
something missing.
User reserve k bytes 131072.
What's what's up there?
Which one? Sorry.
Min free k bytes is five zero one.
Oh, so that's saying that we have to
keep this number of kilobytes available,
which does not means they can't be allocated
by the kernel. So we could probably just
do
echo zero over the top of that.
Oh. Well,
there's a there's a CTL way of resetting
it to its default,
which is not what you're doing here.
I like the sledgehammer approach. I would just
have
cat echo as you know, right over the
top of that and assist our system. But
how can we reset with this CTL?
You'll actually
Hold on.
Read values from system directory. Yeah.
That's that's system.
Alright. Let's see if that changed our VM
minimum
allocatable.
No. It's still ridiculously
high. At least I I I think that's
high.
Let's try the sledgehammer. Let's
let's jump into another I would jump into
another host to see what it is. So
it's probably it's probably something that's
reasonable,
but it should be set at.
I'm a big fan of, like, having an
example of something that should that is working
the way it's supposed to and then comparing
that with the thing that is not working
with it. It.
I'm not happy with the performance of this
machine either, to be fair.
Yeah. And free
So let's make it that. I'd be happier
with that change.
Alright. So echo
oh, I didn't copy properly. 7584.
You can echo it in, or you can
also do system d system CTL dash w,
and then the argument equals the value. Either
way either way works.
What
was it?
Men
three Three k bytes.
Okay.
Alright. Okay. Cool. And that's already snappy,
like Now, that's like a top. Yeah.
Okay. But In fact, we could run out
back in. Free dash h. Yeah.
We've got available sexy kick there. Okay. We're
back to business. Let's
see if you can join the session again.
For this.
And
I
am
options, join session.
Back in business.
So sneaky.
Alright. So I guess what we wanna do
now is get the Kubelet and API server
back into the
manifest directory and see if we can find
some sense of normality here.
One hopes.
Okay.
Hey.
Copy?
Yes. Let's see.
Thanks,
Jason.
Normal is relative.
That fills me with great hope.
Let's see. I'll be right I'll be right
back in just one second. Okay? Of course.
If you wanna see if the API server
comes up, that'd be awesome. Alright. No worries.
Alright. So the API server is back in
here.
I guess I should use crack control.
Nothing
there.
Oh, why
it just slow? Am I being very impatient?
No,
there we go. Nice.
Okay.
So we have an API server.
I can't remember if we took this link,
but let's see if we can do
We can. Okay.
We've got two nodes not ready.
Ship system namespace.
Obviously, missing a couple of things, but it
doesn't look too bad.
And my actual application,
database is terminating, let's
try and move it over the rest of
these manifests.
Like I definitely took things nice and slow
and one by one and was trying to
verify things and I just gonna
it'll be fine.
Okay. Scheduler, good. Controller manager, good. Oh, running.
Once they could just
Let's see.
Don't keep system namespace.
I fixed it all. Get off the hook.
Oh, you can't hear me yet. Oh,
you can.
Alright.
So I've moved Alright. Job done. Too easy.
Moved those manifest back. The API server came
up. I put the controller manager, the scheduler
back end. They appear to be coming up.
We can speak to the API server.
Control manager's not quite healthy yet, but I
think it's getting there.
We still I ran and get nodes. We
still got two of them down. There's still
two worker nodes that need a little bit
of CPR.
But the Kubernetes control point does seem to
be
okay.
I will say okay.
Fine. Okay.
So we probably
wanna jump on to D R 44 and
Q P Q
Unless there's something else on here that we
need to check out.
Dang it.
Was really close on that one too. You
know? That's
Getting better. Yeah. There we go.
Alright. So I think you're right. I think
what I wanna see
just look at these other two mental. I
think I would like to just real quick
for my own
verification.
Is that controller list that suspect?
No. That's maybe okay. I just that star
kinda threw me. Yeah.
That looks okay.
Okay. And then cat.
Pretty simple. Okay.
Oh, okay. Now it's okay.
Alright.
Just out of curiosity.
Nothing suspicious
there.
Oh, you're looking for pod security policy.
Yeah. I was just curious. These are places
where I I would, like
feel like one of the things I should
have done earlier was this one for sure
because we are on a Cilium cluster.
Oh, alright. Okay. Well, let's go see if
we can get our notes back. Get get
all
get notes.
Let's jump over to D R 44 B.
There's a session open if you just wanna
join that one.
Oh, cool. I'll just join that one.
Do you wanna start a session on the
other one too? Yep. Got it.
Alright. We have sessions.
I'm on DR44B
right now.
I'm not sure what I'm on.
Hold on. Close that. Config here.
KDR443
active sessions. There we go. Now I see
it. Alright. So 443.
We have a kubelet. It's active and running.
Nothing suspicious.
Logs.
Request that. Reload.
Okay.
We have a kubelet, but we're not ready.
It's a good sign.
No errors.
No obvious errors.
That's true.
Oh, there we go.
Cannot
connection refused
on the docker socket on the container d
socket. Yeah. It can't speak to container d.
Okay.
Yeah. That's not running.
Think we're
don't think be that easy though. No. I
don't think that's gonna run for long.
That's that thing again. Okay.
I'm
gonna add that to my automation for spinning
up these clusters so we don't have to
configure every single thing.
So a couple of things we've been doing
in this session, which I've really been enjoying.
Right? One is that we are in our
own hurry. We're not in anybody else's hurry.
Right? I know that that's hard to accomplish
sometimes,
but
it definitely brings some
I'm enjoying the to what we're trying. The
chillness and the the thinking and the the
talking process.
Yeah. It's it's it's working well. You know
what our targets are? Like, we're moving through
it. Like, one of the things that is,
like, one of the things that that I
think
the show probably could use a little bit
of is, like, just remember that, like, no
matter what, like, everybody in this audience, shout
out if you're with the audience,
is is rooting for us. Like, everybody is
rooting for us. We can't we literally cannot
fail in this scenario. There's absolutely no way
to do it.
But no matter how hard it looks like
it's going to be or how difficult it
is, like, know that you're that that that
things are always gonna be on your side.
I'm gonna jump back over to this
master and see if we've cleared this problem.
Okay. Session.
Odes.
Yeah. K. We got E r 44 b
back. Let's take a look at q p
So starting container d was all we had
to do there?
I know. I know. I'm I'm
I'm
nervous. I've got suspicious eyes for sure on
that one. But
alright. Let's I'll take it. Well, it's it's
a subtle trick. Like, they probably expected that
to be more subtle than it was because,
like,
the way it works, like, it would look
like things are still running. Right? Pods are
still active and running. Why isn't it working?
But you if you didn't know that container
d was broken, then it might take you
a while to get there.
That's true. So And it's easy to overlook
the obvious. Definitely. I think I've done that
time and time again.
Alright. What are you thinking? We should jump
out to q p q? You wanna get
that one? Yeah.
I'm a jump on the q p q.
Exactly. There's a active session there if you
just join it.
That is where I am. Oh, looks like
our
oh, wait a minute. It says it's killed.
Why did it say killed?
Yeah.
Would have killed?
Oh, I see. It's a reload. Uh-huh.
Why why is that being killed, do you
think?
You're looking for suspicious processes?
I am.
Smiley face from Jason.
Assuming that's, like, a suspicious processes.
Yeah. I think
that's our teleport.
Why is it saying killed? Something is
the other possibility the other one was so
easy, and then this was really where they're
gonna make it shine for us. Alright. So
let's see.
Something is sending the cubelet a kill. A
sick kill. Yeah.
That could be fun to find.
Hoping that I would see, like, you know,
some dumb little script somewhere, like, sending a
kill.
Yeah. Well, Jason did leave us a comment.
He said, why honk with a suspicious process
when you can have the system honk for
you?
Fair.
Memory max 64 k.
Yeah.
I would do it.
So good. Terrible people.
Oh,
they even reload.
Well, the sick kill wasn't on because
of a bad setting.
And I agree Bill Gates quote there from
Jason in the chat, who needs more than
64 k of memory?
Right. I mean That was amusing. That was
amusing.
I'm
gonna jump on to the control plane just
to run get nodes and
we've lost a D r d r 44
has died on us again. Our our starting
of container d I do not think was
enough.
Excellent.
Excellent. But we do have
q q ready,
if that helps.
Oh,
we'll leave that one. We'll leave q q
working itself out for a while, and then
we'll jump back over to
I think that would have been as swift
as possible. But let's jump on to D
R 44.
Yeah.
That's 99.
I still have a d r four. Yeah.
There we go. Nice.
So we're seeing
oh,
network namespace. Too
many open files.
I feel like when we start to container
d, we've let list a dragon.
I think you might be right.
Too many open files. Check network namespace. Close.
CNI.
Too many open files. Okay. So
That probably wasn't what I wanted. I want
let's let's see.
We dash I.
Oh, you're trying to do the I nodes
as d f dash I. Yeah.
At least get dot 2%.
So freeze.
I mean, we maybe it's a good limit?
It could be.
Could be to
max,
what's it called?
Oh, fail max.
Oh, no. Okay.
That's that's pretty big.
Too many open files.
File ticket usage for snapshot. Oh, wait. You
know what? Usage for snapshot is probably a
a red herring.
Is
that in the logs?
Now this one is kinda checked, though.
Where are you Yeah. We see too many
oh,
sorry. I was scrolling back up in the
history. Yeah.
We don't share our scroller portion of that.
So
Yeah. That is unfortunate.
Yeah. I don't think it I don't know.
Doesn't particularly like that. Yeah?
Lots of too many open files.
It shut down again. Right? No. It's still
running. Yeah. It looks okay on my end.
I'm just
scrolling, scrolling, scrolling.
I'm take a look at when we started
container d. Right? So we need to know
what containers are running and maybe find a
bad apple.
Yeah.
Possibly.
Oh, you know what? You were just saying
this yourself.
Let's see Kubernetes.
Okay.
That's good. Try dash here. I mean
Do you put
It's
the right place.
What if this starts with a dot?
Wait. What?
I was just curious if they had a
head and dot fail.
Oh, I don't think we get caught.
Alright.
Could they have over
could it be a fake fail system? You
know what? Let's
look at this real quick. Let's go back
to master for a sec for the control
plane for a second. Sorry. Keep it all.
Subscribe node.
Oh, you want to see what states
Cisco okay. That's a good idea.
Saying node ready.
Rawkode notes again.
Hold on. Reading this. Memory pressure, false.
Disc pressure, false.
Grid pressure, false. Ready, true.
Keyblade is posting a ready status.
Did I go to the wrong one?
I don't get notes.
Having that
dining on red herring kind of feeling.
Inter intermittent problem.
That's fine, really.
The pods.
Alright. Should we test my app? Yes.
We should.
Remember on your you're on 13 now.
Yep.
I'm setting up the port forward,
heading the web,
and we got version one.
Okay. But that means we're hitting the database.
It does. So now we can do a
edit deployment
clustered.
Version two.
Continue creating for past scheduling.
Mental note to pre fill the images. Although,
people may mess with them, I guess.
There we go.
Okay.
Yep.
Are you are you using fish or c
s h?
C s h.
That's all. There we go. Oh, it's actually
gonna
I worked on this cluster.
Nice.
We got the happy dance
even though I'm not smiling. I like the
happy dance.
May your bag be bountiful and your success
be great.
I love it. Is that us? Well, heck.
Jason,
how are we doing?
I think we got all awful.
It says down to the final honk,
but then it says the.
Something's
weird here.
Yeah. Especially
with that d r 44 node, which was
ready, unready with too many open files and
then ready again.
I'm sure if we left it long enough
that our d r 44 b would maybe
disappear, but for now it's healthy. Our app
is working. We did our upgrade.
I'm calling that a win. Yeah.
I think we're I think we're gonna fall
into the trap of, like, other operations folks.
Those nodes are looking beautiful, Jason. Look at
how happy they are. They're all ready.
There's no, like, unreadiness.
Yep. They look ready, Jason.
I think one one of your geese may
have fallen down a hole.
Jason says that no What time Bob? What
time hey. It is it's working right now
though. You know what I mean? And, like,
it's time for lunch. And so we're gonna
go have lunch, and then we're gonna, like,
you know no kidding.
Like the classic the classic the the classic
it's working here. It's working for me problem.
Works on my machine.
We deployed our update. We've seen the happy
dance. The happy dance is the aim of
the game. I I I think we smashed
it. Well, you know, I didn't do a
lot of the heavy lifting, but still I
was here to witness it. So Yep. Happy.
Alright. I had a blast. Thank you very
much. I look forward to breaking or fixing
again.
One of the things I explained to you
before that I would totally be happy to
extend to you again is that, like, you
can always if you're if you're getting a
situation where you feel like you wanna dial
a friend,
you got my number.
Appreciate that. Definitely. Thank you very much, Duffy.
Thank you for I know we went way
over what we plan to do there.
But thank you for your patience and persistence.
Thank you to our breakers as well.
To say I'm Yep. Dan and to Jason.
We know there's a time bomb.
If you wanna close chaos, you gotta do
it harder than that. We're gonna run away
before before it breaks again.
But thanks everybody. Yep. Thank you, Duffy. I'll
speak to you also and have a have
a wonderful day. Thanks.
Have a bunch of fun.